foreign
good morning
um
down
here
I know yeah I know who those guys are
too
sorry
so
important
should I just not should I think you'll
always have electronic hobby no no you
everything
else
because I do
foreign
okay
I wasn't talking
okay and on that good news we'll open it
up
all right I am going to call to order uh
this meeting of the house election law
committee
um we'll start off with the pledge uh
representative wood you want to do the
honors
okay
all right so uh to answer the question
for if you saw scurring around a minute
ago we were trying to find out if you
had to have a quorum to have a public
hearing because we have 50 not 51 uh and
the clerk has said we do not need 51 to
hold a public hearing so that's why we
are a little delayed uh I'm going to
open the public hearing on House Bill
excuse me House Bill 336 relative to the
format of election bouts uh welcome
representative Cahill to election law
thank you very much Mr chair and members
of the committee
I had to begin with telling you this
this bill needs a little work it will
need an amendment and uh
I hope we can work through this uh but
the the idea here is for for many of us
you know we we have a 400 member house
and not many of those uh seats are in
and then uh boards but in
sort of
like for example in my district of New
Market and new Fields neither town has
Wards so we are three representatives in
a forterio and all of us have the whole
territory there are no Awards so that on
the ballot as I was giving you a copy of
last year's general election uh results
you'll see that there are three
three Republicans three Democrats and
1725 undervotes
and that's why I'm here today but I this
is the first year that the uh Secretary
of State's office has recorded the
number of blanks when I've been hearing
my moderator you know read off the
number of blanks and you know 1200 you
know et cetera you know it just seems a
little high
so while we can't compel someone to vote
for someone in every you know each of
those people I think it might be useful
to let them know that uh whether or not
they do participate and vote that far
down the ballot uh that number of people
will be elected and we'll be up here in
Concord you know sponsoring and voting
on bills so it I think it couldn't hurt
and it might help
so that's what this is that's what this
bill is about
and what this really think of everything
below line six on the bill as not being
as really an if then statement or a case
statement if you like
so we wouldn't be putting if you look at
line five we wouldn't be
where it says below each so such phrase
it would really be the appropriate
phrase if there's if there's one only
one to be elected for the for the
position then we would say uh vote for
not more than one
next to that one
and in the case where there are multiple
candidates in multiple positions uh you
would say vote for up to in the case of
New Market three
and that would be all this other bolded
uh italic forget about it uh if you
would uh just over here next to line
five the appropriate and insert a
quotation uh in line seven after the one
followed immediately by a parentheses
and another parentheses at the end of
where it says on line eight District
column
so then there's an or if an or
and then we would have more uh
more editing on the second on the B
statement so again we're not doing all
of this printing all this text it's just
going to be where there's one can be
elected or one choice between one
in one position we'll do one thing if
there's three four five seven candidates
in Derry or whatever we'll do a
different thing
and I I think this may help so that
people will say well I shouldn't write
Mickey Mouse I should uh choose from the
above people or a serious write-in if I
know there is a campaign for someone
that I would like better but I should
probably pick my best shot on either
side of the ballot that number and not
more which we know leads to overvotes
questions from Vinnie yes representative
Kinney
uh yeah when I was reading this I mean
it seemed a little complicated and then
I couldn't understand why this was
better than vote for not more than one
or vote for not more than four
I mean what is it what does it do that
that statement doesn't do
um
vote for not more than and vote for up
to mean the same thing but votes for
updo seems a bit more welcoming uh and
encouraging than vote for not more of
that
uh yes representative prudham O'Brien
thank you
I'm looking at the
ballot
that you provided right that's from you
okay
and there aren't a lot of overvotes on
here and the races where there is only
one
um I'm only seeing one over vote and
I just
if you're looking at the State State Rep
follow-up follow-up thank you wouldn't
an undervote reflect the will of the
voter also if a voter only thought two
people in a race with three open seats
were their choice wouldn't that be
reflected in the undervotes
so that's their choice uh yes yes I
would agree with that and there's
nothing in this additional step that
tells them they can't make that choice
it just clarifies it and you know sort
of helps them understand that that will
that that will be the result that three
people will be elected in this case
uh whether or not they make that choice
follow-up another question is thank you
did people in your community Express
that they were finding it confusing the
way it is now and is that what this is
to
fix
um I haven't heard from people in my
community that that it is confusing but
as I understand from talking with my
moderator who talks with other
moderators it's prevalent across the
state it's not just my community and I
think that you might agree that uh
because you know in the state
legislature doesn't get as much press as
the as Congress or the president or uh
the Red Sox so that people aren't
necessarily tuned into who we are what
it is that we do
um and so I I really and if you if
you've looked at your ballots in your
community you might see that people vote
at the top and then get kind of tired we
have tried telling suggesting people
they vote from the bottom up but that
doesn't seem to to register so I thus
that actually that the language the
language about the uh inserting the
number that will be elect that comes
from the honorable Susan hamola who
noticed my bill uh prior to submitted
prior to the election and this is an
issue that she was working on and that's
that's her part
so it's not just Newmarket
yeah
representative
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking the question on for state
representative the undervote 1725 when
you agree I mean remember back in 2002
to 2012 there was in litfield Hudson and
Pelham they were vote for no more than
13. and and Windham Salem was similar
that and I bet then the undervotes would
have been a whole lot more because don't
you think that with the undervote people
are bullet voting
that's certainly a possibility and again
we can't prevent nor maybe we shouldn't
prevent that but people can and do will
do as they please this is just a bit
more information
you know that may that can't hurt and it
might help
further questions
representative
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you
uh
am I correct in thinking that the only
difference a voter would see on a ballot
is the change from the phrase not more
than to the phrase up to uh no there's
the in the case where there are multiple
candidates multiple sorry multiple
offices open they would see the number
of uh votes were up to that number of
that number so that's that's that's the
difference
maybe my follow-up Please Mr chairman
yes and represent Boone can you turn
your microphone off thank you uh
maybe I'm uh remembering incorrectly but
my uh memory of the ballots is that it
says if you've got eight
reps in a district that says vote for
not more than eight it does and this
would say vote for up to eight yes okay
thank you oh I'm sorry man it will also
say eight will be elected
in that case that sort of reinforces the
then okay that thank you take your best
pick yeah right got it thank you that
that makes it clear to me thank you very
much thank you further questions
um I just have a couple
um so the goal here is to make it uh
more clear clearer
um how many you get to vote for yes
um what about field abductive follow
what about um so like let's take the
standard that's your only multi-canon
race
um what if it said three or less
because I I tend to agree with you like
vote for not more than three sounds a
little confusing like it seems a little
Antiquated
um
but I think that might be a an easier
change than
all of this
we do have balance based issues too but
I'm sure the secretary of state will
probably bring up right well again it's
it's either vote for up to which is
not just a couple of words or vote for
less than
uh
I'm I'm I wouldn't I wouldn't object to
that but that's not you know you you
have the committee I I just sponsored
the bill but I do prefer up to because I
think that it does sound a bit more
inviting you know like uh
don't don't take more but have help
yourself
take you know this is what's available
to you
fair enough we'll probably send this off
to an English Professor somewhere who
will write you know some dissertation
about it you can use AI
uh representative Brian thank you I I
have many questions so
um
I'm looking at where it says state
representative Rockingham district 10 on
this ballot in my community it would be
rocking it would be state representative
Rockingham District 13. so then
underneath that in my community it would
say
uh vote for not more than 10.
Representatives 10 Representatives will
be elected in this District vote for up
to 10. if there are more than a single
person to be voted for in that column
such as some House of Representative
districts would all of that be on the
ballot no
this is this is where the punctuation is
is lacking on on what you have before
you so what it would say is yeah that's
that's a bit much and yeah
um I think what it would really say
under here is instead of vote for not
more than three
it would say
uh
vote for up to three
and uh three three will be elected or it
might say yes I think that's that's
pretty concise
you could just say three will be elected
you know and put the uh vote for yeah I
think I think vote for not more than
three and three will be elected so that
sort of lets you know this is this is
your parameters these are your options
okay further questions from the
committee
supersonic okay you made the mistake of
sponsoring a bill in the minutia and
that's where this Committee just loves
to loves to go at it you were not here
for column rotation Day last year which
I went for two and a half hours so you
you do not know what you have done uh
thank you so much uh for your time thank
you and I I do welcome the uh
fine-tuning and uh and look forward to
seeing that fair enough
um only have one other pink card about
this um deputy secretary uh Saint Aaron
Hennessey that's my last pink card so if
male's wish to speak please get your
pink card in and we'll be moving on
welcome to election law deputy secretary
thank you Mr chair good to see you
everybody I'm glad you all made it in
today
um I just wanted to
um let the committee know that uh in
speaking with the sponsor of this
legislation we are happy to work with
him and with you of the committee if
you're
um open to making the wording on the
ballot more clear
um or more positive vote for up to
versus vote not for not more than
um the the sponsor of legislation is
aware and we have the discussion that
there's some missing
um punctuation and parentheses in the
wrong spots here but
um as to the chair's Point uh there is a
limited amount of space on the ballot so
if we can make whatever wording we do
change or we do add just to be very
minimal just to make sure that it's um
legible by the uh it's a voter can
easily read it and it's not too much
information where they wouldn't just
ignore it to begin with so
okay questions from the committee
a representative
um
I don't know that's why I have like
question I was just wondering
and and I'm just maybe ignorant to why
thank you for the question I I believe
it's because the voter has the option to
vote for none one two or three or they
can they can vote for more than that if
they'd like to
um vote
um they are our lawyer in um the
Secretary of State's office often uses
the example of when he runs for dog
catcher and somebody's well his neighbor
says he's going to vote for him but his
neighbor also says he's going to vote
for promises vote to somebody else who's
running for dog catcher and he votes for
both of them he can honestly say I voted
for you so
um
thank you
it just it tells the voter that they can
bullet vote if they want to I think I
think that's the reasoning behind it but
it's up to you as the legislature to
decide that that wording
representative
uh thank you
um
along the lines of that question
does vote for up to does that imply they
have to vote for that number I'm just
asking because when I first read it it's
like what happens if they're sitting
there saying I don't want to vote for up
to three
I'm just wondering does it create even
more confusion
thank you for the question I I think I
would leave it up to the sponsor and
your committee and we're happy to give
our input as anything that can make it
clearer for the the voter as to how many
they can vote for
um and in a positive way perhaps the
word not is not a positive word to be in
there but
okay I don't know if uh representative
wood
thank you Mr chair
um
how long have we been collecting the
thank you for the question since
November
25 of 2020.
so it's this is new data do oh actually
September sorry
do you see do you believe there's a
problem with the number of under on the
votes
uh from the data you've seen have you
looked at it do you see a lot of those I
mean just
people handle numbers they they get a
sense I was just wondering now that
you're seeing these numbers for the
first time do you think there's a
problem with people reading this well
I think
um to what the sponsor of the bill said
and I think somebody else on the
committee alluded to is that as the as
you go down the ballot you get voter
fatigue a little bit and sometimes when
you flip over the ballot you might not
know what one of the county officers
does so you just
don't vote that way and especially in
vote for up to 10 or 13 or whatever have
you for state representatives
um you might not know that many people
and you want to vote for the ones you do
know so I don't I don't know that
there's a problem on the with the
undervotes so much as just making sure
that it's clear that they can vote for
that many
of course
um
100 in Bowman said that if we had 13 he
would expect to see that number uh
bigger would you agree with that from
the data you've seen yes I would
definitely agree with that okay thank
you that's really the question okay
further questions all right never
underestimate why voters do what they do
I mean after all they did vote for all
of us so uh thank you deputy secretary I
don't have anyone else I don't have any
more pink cards uh representative wood
okay
thank you oh and it's blank so perfect
uh the clerk have a that's going to be a
tough one to process
I'm going to close the uh public hearing
on HB 336 we will reconvene right at 11
okay the Google machine says it is 11.
so we are going to fire off a house bill
363.
um
representative C welcome to read the
book relative to the deadline of
cannabis filing my nomination papers for
the state general elections uh
representative C welcome to election law
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
election law committee I'm
representative Alvin C representing
Merrimack County District 26. I'm here
today to introduce House Bill 363 an act
relative to deadlines for the candidates
filing by nomination papers for state
general elections
candidates filing by nomination papers
are running
either as an independent or as a part of
a minor political party
these candidates have four deadlines to
meet in order to get on state general
election ballot these deadlines are
currently based on the date of the
primary election
but these candidates are not
participating in the primary at all
so synchronizing the deadlines
to the primary is an odd way of doing
things
and there's consideration for changing
the date of the primary so it makes
sense to decouple the petition process
from the primary election
and reference the several deadlines to
the date of the general election
then regardless of whether or not the
date of the primary has changed stay
possible unintended consequence may be
avoided
the first part of this bill changes the
filing of a declaration of intent
from when the party candidates must file
their for their primaries in early June
to the third Monday in July moving this
deadline from June to July is the only
notable change in this bill
this can help minor parties if they hold
nominating conventions which could be
scheduled as late as early summer
the other three deadlines for nomination
papers currently are each defined as a
certain number of weeks before the
primary election date this bill uses the
same weeks but will now Define them as
certain weeks before the general
election instead of the primary election
thank you for your attention to this
bill and I'll be happy to answer any
questions you may have
look at that you're getting off easy
thank you representative C I have no
other pink cards for this bill
um representative wood will you grab the
and maybe it's time for a jaunt down to
thank you and so once again it's a blank
sheet so with that I'm going to close
the public hearing on House Bill 363 and
we will reconvene at 11 30 for house
okay
um I'm gonna
reconvene this uh meeting of the house
election law committee uh next up is HB
um
HP 447 tellerisky
oh there you are
welcome to election did I get your name
right
mailed it representative I did not all
right welcome to election law
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
members of the committee my name is
Laura tolerski and I represent nashua's
Ward 8 which is Hillsboro 11.
today I present for your consideration
House Bill
447fn relative to the purchase of
election equipment
the purpose of this bill is to create an
opportunity for local municipalities to
receive some financial support through
existing Hava funds to pay for the
replacement of ballot counting devices
which we know will be coming as soon as
a new device is selected by the end of
the year
Additionally the bill would allow funds
to be used for other needed election
technology including electronic poll
books and secure laptops
we are all aware that the existing
accuvote machines are at the end of
their life span with software that is
outdated repairs being needed more often
and parts that are getting more
difficult to find
what we want to do is get towns in a
position to be able to replace these
dying machines and prevent an election
election day catastrophe such as a
machine failure that could result in
exhausting handcounts and delayed
results
development of town and City budgets are
always a challenge
and in a perfect world money would have
been set aside over the last few Cycles
in anticipation of this once in a 20 to
30 year purchase of ballot counting
machines
but now with the state taking so long
and making a final decision there is
simply no time left
for many municipalities budgets are
being voted on in a matter of days and
weeks
and it's likely there will be
municipalities that won't be able to
purchase machines once the selection is
made
this just isn't fair to our hard-working
election workers who will be faced with
exhausting hand counts
I've passed out to the committee I
handout that outlines the dedicated
we have extras for anyone here
showing the Hava balance over the last
decade
on the cover sheet is an easier to read
summary
and you can see that the balance has
dropped below 10 million dollars only
twice in that time and never below nine
during the public hearing on a similar
Bill SB 73
the Secretary of State expressed
concerns that they don't want to spend
down these funds as they maintain
certain election functions in their
Department
with that in mind
I would be open to amending my bill
that would set a cap on the amount that
could be distributed to help towns
through this bill
why can't three to five million dollars
be spent through this program providing
grants leaving a healthy balance not at
risk of running out
for example
with the current balance
of 11.9 million which was the balance as
of January 31st
and with an expected one million dollar
Grant
that we are expecting to receive in
April
we can still offer three million dollars
in relief to towns and have nearly 10
million dollars remaining
amending the bill to limit the amount of
grants in that way would allow this very
needed one-time relief for acquiring
nuke technology while maintaining ahava
balance that the secretary would like to
see
while the ballot counting devices are
Paramount for towns this bill also would
allow funds to be spent on other
Technologies such as electronic pull
books and secure laptops it is my
understanding that some supervisors of
the checklist need to access election
net using their own personal devices
which poses an obvious security risk and
providing funds to be used on these
Technologies further secures our
elections
the special committee on voter
confidence report recommended replacing
our ballot counting devices and to use
state and federal funds so that
municipalities have the resources to
conduct efficient and secure elections
this bill addresses both of these
concerns using Hava funds even nominally
will help our towns and be a significant
investment for the state to build
confidence in the security and integrity
of our elections
these machines are not a want for towns
they are in need
I hope you will consider house bill
447fn as a way to provide necessary
relief to our towns and election
officials and I thank you for your time
thank you and I apologize for my phone
that was not that was not intentional
obviously uh representative
you mentioned uh like three million
dollars or whatever but how do you think
the Secretary of State Should allocate
the that amount of money going to Which
towns and Which towns would have more
access than other towns
thank you for the question I trust that
um the secretary of state has would be
able to address that question also but I
would imagine
um that there would be an understanding
um as to the number of machines each
Town currently uses
um or each Town requires and
um I assume it would be based also on
perhaps the number of Voters that are in
each district and they could develop
some kind of guidelines for that
coming from do you know I am unsure I
received that office from the Secretary
of State's office last week I'm sure
they could answer that question all
right thank you
further questions
um I have just some kind of product
questions uh what is a secure laptop
what does that mean
does that defined anywhere or is that
just like I just looked at my pure
laptops I don't I just don't know what
that means was that in my testimony or
I believe that would refer to
um
a municipal laptop that is does not have
someone's um or
referring to what I said about uh
personal devices personal devices that
potentially did not have the needed
security and could be open to some kind
of breach okay um kind of a follow-up
would you be okay if we either took the
word secure out or in some way just I
just feel like somebody's getting like
I'm getting bogged down in it right now
so like I feel like I just don't know
what a secure laptop that's fine I would
talk about somebody who talks about who
programs computers I just don't know
what that means like off offhand if
there's like a standard like there's a
fisma standard uh with the federal
government uh I I just don't know what
secure means I'm not trying to play
games I just literally just don't know
what it means I would leave that open to
the uh committee okay thank you
um other questions about secure laptops
no
all right next up is I'm having trouble
reading the last last name but natch
Grace
yes
Nate Graves with the municipal
Association uh we support uh House Bill
um it is the companion bill to Senate
Bill 73 I will note that for some reason
um LBA did not include a fiscal note
with this bill but there is one on
Senate Bill 73 which you all may want to
take a look at
um
I look in this this a little bit uh
according to the data that I saw from
the Secretary of State's office from
September of 2022 there were 195 towns
and wards that use the accubote machines
um according to the fiscal note they
provided for the um Senate companion
bill direct replacement of those
machines would cost between six thousand
and eight point five thousand per
machine that's a total of 1.17 to 1.65
million for just the new machines that
doesn't necessarily include any sort of
Maintenance costs or you know any
contracts related to that that's just
the hardware itself
um
so that's really what our Focus would be
on is trying to find funding other than
um
locally raised AKA taxpayer funding
um to replace those machines
um as as mentioned the Hava fund is a
potential option here I certainly don't
have any objection if there are other
sources of funding that the legislature
wants to look at
um we're just we are aware of the fact
that
for many years now the uh
company that has been servicing the
machines has said essentially at their
end of life and we hope that the
ballotlaw commission will be quickly
wrapping up the process of certifying uh
new machines and so those will be able
to take the place of the machines that
are frankly older than I am
um and so we're hopeful that we can find
some sort of State funding or federal
funding sources so that we can quickly
replace those and have all of them ready
to go for the next election
um whatever whatever election that may
be
happy to take any questions
from the committee
all right nope representative Kennedy
ask him for two dollars
oh thank you Mr chairman thanks for
taking my question I I probably should
have asked this of the of the sponsor
but this is more just curiosity is do
you know how much money is available
from the help America vote Act of 2002.
so according to the fiscal note that was
on Senate Bill 73 there was 12.7 million
in the Java fund I believe that was
prepared in late December early January
so I don't know if there were costs
associated with
um the November election that were just
paid out or not Secretary of State's
office would have to speak to that but
that's what was reported to the other
body
follow-up
so that's the money available to us
12.7 million
I would assume so
a lot of money uh representative Brennan
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
um I think you mentioned your estimate
on how much the total cost would be for
a replacement of machines can you just
clarify what that would be the total
number sure so there were 195 towns
rewards that that used the accubo
machines so the total number
with me doing the math was between 1.17
million and 1.65 million I think it
depends on
um which uh vendor they they end up
certifying is as able to be replacing
if these Java funds are not made
available to municipalities to replace
these machines who pays for the
replacement of machines
that would be the local taxpayer
thank you
representative Brian thank you sir uh
human nature being what it is
wouldn't communities that currently do
not use
this kind of Technology electronic
ballot counting machines consider this
to be some kind of free money since
previously they would have that
Community would have had to pay for it
now they don't they're seeing that other
communities don't have to do that if
it's being paid for with Java funds and
that would render these estimates
inaccurate at best
wouldn't that start happening so there
are
um
a total of 308 polling places throughout
the state 113 use hand count 195 use uh
ballot counting devices
at this point there wasn't specificity
in the bill as to how the secretary of
state would allocate those funds that
goes to representative bones question if
their interest was direct replacement
it would only be what I told you if it
was the case they wanted to open it up
to
um other the other 113 that we're
looking at it there's
potentially additional costs
I can't do math that quickly but I
assume the total cost of just the
machines without the maintenance would
be somewhere
under 3 million
representative Burnham
thank you Mr chair thank you for my
taking my question
um who actually in the town will be
approving these purchases
of the Machines of new machines or any
other devices so if it's a grant program
any sort of unanticipated it would be
considered unanticipated money it could
be accepted by the select board assuming
the select board has been authorized by
the town meeting to do so under RSA 3195
B and they could expend any of those
Grant funds in line with the purpose of
the grant so that would be if it covered
the whole the whole cost machine if
there's some sort of match or there's
some sort of local allocation that would
have to be done as part of the budgeting
process which would occur at town
meeting
obviously cities are different but okay
thank you
further questions just representative
boom
thank you Mr chairman uh you mentioned
the number of
places that have the machines and be
replaced does that include you have a
total number of machines not the total
number of talents
I can get you the link to the
spreadsheet from the Secretary of
State's website that gives you data
about that I think it was 195 machines
total but I could be wrong about that I
know that was
the wards and towns it's possible that
some awards have more than one machine
or they I know that they do I I don't
know that that was in my account
follow-up yeah and my question is
the amount of money you said I mean
that's what we need for right is the
total number of machines that are going
to pay for not the total number of
towns or whatever
like I said I can give you the I I will
forward to the committee the uh the link
to the spreadsheet on the Secretary of
State's website that tells you which
town and how many machines
so you can check my math
further questions
all right it's pretty easy thank you
thank you uh next up Olivia zinc with
good morning members of the committee I
hope you all got here safely and we'll
get home safely in the snowstorm
um for the record my name is Olivia Zink
I live in Franklin and I represent open
democracy action
um a non-partisan non-profit based here
in Concord local election officials are
the Bedrock of our democracy and they
deserve more support House Bill 447
helps election workers with the
resources needed to replace ballot
devices we just heard that we have over
300 polling places I have the list
printed out of the 129 towns or
communities that have ballot counting
devices but my city the city of Franklin
has three Wards three polling places and
three ballot counting devices
so this list just has the date of the
when the device was purchased not how
many devices each Community has so if
there's another spreadsheet that would
be great to have
Candia and Canterbury both purchase
devices February 8
1996 so making those machines
27 years old
they were purchased when I was in high
school
it may be time for us to be looking at
new devices
we know due to an nhpr story
um that the ballot counting devices
starting in 2024 State manufacturers
will no longer be able to produce parts
for the older models
these machines are in need of parts and
services and will need to be replaced in
the next two years
as we've heard the Secretary of State's
office has 12.8 million dollars of Hava
funds that could be used to out to
purchase these machines this grant
system might operate similar to the
cares Grant system during covid where
municipalities were able to receive
Grant monies in administering the
elections I urge you to please vote
ought to pass if House Bill
447 and happy to take any questions
questions from the committee
yes representative Britain thank you and
thank you for taking my question
if these ballot counting devices fail in
2024 and there's no parts
what happens to the counting of ballots
who who is doing that
the election workers would would do a
hand count if a if a device fails
follow up please of course
in Manchester
if there is a failure of
ballot counting machines in 2024 which
would be a presidential election which
I would think would result in a higher
voter participation more ballots
do you know how long it would take
um election workers to hand count in in
a large municipality like a Manchester
or or another
um Manchester might be the wrong example
because I know that if a machine fails
in Manchester they've moved a machine
from a different polling place because
Manchester has multiple machines but say
it's dairy or another Bedford is another
large municipality it would take hours
and I would think that you would want to
pull a whole team in seven o'clock if
you knew you were hand counting for hand
counting and I know that at least in
2022 Town clerks and moderators were in
search of people to come in to do the
seven o'clock shift to help count so
that was a need
um
and I think that it in other communities
where there's smaller hand counts it
takes hours if not you know two or three
in the morning that you're there hand
I remember from previous testimony that
the Secretary of State's office had
talked about recruit the need to recruit
more volunteers for
um working elections
um
phrases
if a large municipality is potentially
facing
um
hours and hours and hours of hand
counting what do you think that would do
to the recruitment of election worker
volunteers
um I think that
um it's right now difficult to recruit
election workers I know I'm a single mom
I work the polls in my community and I'm
lucky my mom takes my daughter overnight
on Election night because I say just
keep her overnight because I don't know
what time I'm going to be home but I
think that we're seeing more of that
grandparent generation age out of being
poll workers and the need to recruit
more Working Families and others to be
poll workers and I think that
as that transition begins to happen
where you have more working families
that have to get up and go to work most
you know the next morning it's going to
be hard to make a commitment to our
democracy that that needs to stay up
until several hours into the night I
know
um I remember talking to representative
Kathy holzel on this committee and she
said to me I was up until 3 A.M in
Raymond
um and she's like it's gonna take me a
couple of days to
feel like a normal human being again she
was back here in election law after that
election but I do think we're not used
to working that many hours many I mean I
know in my town clerk went to work at
four in the morning to get the elections
ready to be opened and worked until 4
a.m during the primary and she worked a
24-hour day our town clerks are you know
it happens every so often but I do think
what were the questions from the
committee all right seeing none thank
you next up representative Alvin C from
Loudon
thank you Mr chairman members of the
election law committee I just wanted to
point out that all the cities and towns
have already been notified that of the
pending obsolescence of the accuvote
machines
um
my town of Loudon has already
been well our budget hasn't been
approved yet this year but in this
year's budget we'll have a line item for
new uh voting machines so
um Township and towns and cities should
be planning ahead and I don't think it's
necessarily appropriate for
the state to suddenly be giving grants
to towns that didn't plan ahead when
there are towns that are planning ahead
by putting it in the ballot in their
budget this year or maybe next year
so I just wanted to pass that on thank
you fair enough questions will you be
taking questions I'll take questions if
there are any questions on the committee
seeing none thank you next up McKenzie
good morning member of the committee my
name is Mackenzie St Germain I'm the
campaign director for the New Hampshire
campaign for voting rights and America
votes New Hampshire I'm here today in
support of HB 447 this legislation is
really crucial to support our towns our
election officials and our overall
election infrastructure as we need to
replace our aging ballot counting
devices and the current ballot counting
device we use New Hampshire cities and
towns was first introduced in 1989 as
others have said soldier than them it's
also older than me these devices are no
longer built they're no longer available
for sale parts are no longer
manufactured so any parts that are
needed need to be taken from old
machines and put into functioning ones
in 2019 the president of LHS Associates
which is the company that Services the
accuvote devices expressed concerns
about the software used with the
machines since they use Windows XP which
is an operating system that has not been
supported by Microsoft in years another
example of kind of the need for new ones
and Connecticut these devices are also
used their primary is in the summertime
they had a very hot primary day and the
devices started melting there are
stories about this as we talk about
moving the primary potentially in the
state these are all things we really
need to think about in terms of the
urgency of replacing these devices as
soon as possible in 2022 Union Leader
article LHS associates also spoke before
the committee on voter competence they
said their intention was to support this
machine through the 2024 election we are
getting close to that date and that this
techno technology is phasing out the
system that we use although these
machines are still function functioning
and accurate New Hampshire communities
are really fun working on borrowed time
right now if these devices need parts on
Election Day or in the lead up to
election day that are not available from
other machines if towns have software
issues even large towns will need to
hand Count Their ballots which adds
stress to our election officials and
also puts at risk are timely same night
election results which New Hampshire
voters expect and they should expect and
if folks are voting are counting until
early early in the morning that puts at
risk those same night results and it
also puts at risk voter confidence
the ballot commission is currently
working on certifying the new devices
but none have been approved yet so
without support from the state's the
state towns will be required to purchase
their own election equipment funding
these purchases from their own budgets
um the Secretary of State recently
shared before this committee um your
orientation I believe that there were
12.8 million dollars in the America
Funds account
um one of these specifically mentioned
uses for help America vote act funds on
the help America vote act website which
is available for everyone to see is
replacing and updating voting systems so
this directly fits into the purpose of
those funds utilizing a purchase of
these already existing Hollow funds is a
fiscally responsible choice removes the
burden from town budgets and protects
our election infrastructure you know I
think I can assume everyone on this
committee has an interest in Saving
taxpayer dollars in making fiscally
responsible decisions where we can and
utilizing funds that already exist to
fund these important purchases and this
bill does exactly that it makes sure
that our elections can continue to run
smoothly and supports the election
infrastructure and the election
officials who are really the backbone of
our New Hampshire elections finally I
wanted to add that this legislation does
meet two of the recommendations made by
the special committee on voter
confidence last year one was to replace
our ballot accounting devices and the
other was to utilize state and federal
funds to implement the report's
recommendations and enable local
communities to have the resources needed
to conduct their elections so thank you
for your time and I am happy to answer
any questions
questions from the committee
all right thank you
last up uh is the Secretary of State
uh representative wood can you go ahead
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee I'm David Scanlon Secretary of
State and I appear today in opposition
to
house bill 447.
there are actually two issues being
discussed at this hearing today
one more than others
the big factor is the the need or the
urgency to replace our existing ballot
counting devices
it is an urgent issue I don't agree that
it as as urgent as has been expressed in
some of the testimony today
um you know we have time and the ballot
commission is aggressively working
towards the approval of a new device
that could be put in place
uh maybe by 2024 for some
communities but more likely something
that would be ready for 2026.
that issue however is being used as a
reason to raid the election fund which
contains the federal Java Monies
supplied through the passage of the help
America vote act in 2003. and this is an
issue that has been coming before the
legislature now for the last probably
half a dozen years if not more
and those states that have spent down
their Harbor funds on
items like this are now going before the
federal government asking for for more
money to fund their election processes
when the help America vote Act passed in
there were certain things that were
required by the federal government one
that every state
had or created a Statewide centralized
voter database
two that there would be accessible
voting equipment in every polling place
that there would be
substantive poll worker training that
would take place as a result of those
funds voter education and then monies
available to the Attorney General's
office to enforce the provisions of the
at the time New Hampshire received about
17 million dollars as its share of those
funds to get that job done
and the legislature at the time created
the policy of allowing the Secretary of
State's office to spend a portion of
those funds on an annual basis to meet
the requirements of the help America
vote Act
so that the funds could be kept
ideally in perpetuity but as long as
possible before the monies would be
spent down and we would have to tap
around state general fund our state
taxpayer dollars to fund those programs
so here we are 20 years after the help
America vote Act passed we have a a fund
that is in excess of 12 million dollars
at the moment that has allowed us to
spend
right around a million dollars every
year uh to administer the help America
vote act mandates
so what have we done uh with those
monies well uh we probably spent about
six million dollars of the initial funds
that we received early on
to create a brand new centralized voter
database and add uniformity to that
process
we put an accessible voting system in
every polling place
and we're currently on the third
generation of accessible voting
equipment in the polling place and we're
working on enhancements to that
those items are paid for out of the
election fund
in addition to that we have a an
excellent poll worker training program
that we've been able to expand every
year
uh where uh individuals and and the
Secretary of State's office travel
around the state
uh putting on training sessions for
local election officials
and in addition to that we have uh
uh started putting those trainings up uh
online whether it's on YouTube or
whether they're WebEx trainings
so that they can be used multiple times
in an election cycle
that training has to be updated every
year because of the laws that are passed
by the legislature and those laws have
to be reflected in the training
materials that we put on I think all of
you have a copy of the election
procedure manual and you've seen how
thick that has gotten over the years but
yeah that is the result of the activity
that we undertake with the funds with
uh
the federal government has given us
additional funds over the years in
uh to try and get my dates right but
around 2020 when cyber security was a
big issue we received a significant
amount of money I believe was around
three million dollars to address
concerns that were initiated by Foreign
actors hacking into state election
databases
and so we use those funds to uh you know
put in place important protections uh
penetration testing you know embedded
Security in our in our database and
things like that
uh and then the balance of those funds
uh uh we were able to use to actually
bring the balance of the fund up to
where it should be because it had been
dropping over the years due to low
interest rates
and then in 2022
um
I'm sorry it would have been 2020. it
would have actually the security funds
would have been probably around 2018
2020 we had the pandemic
and we received an additional 3.2
million dollars in federal funds for the
pandemic all of which except for uh
about three hundred thousand dollars we
sent directly to the cities and towns
through a grant process which was
established
by the number of absentee ballots that a
community sent out we kept it simple
uh the three hundred thousand dollars we
had to use to hire a CPA firm
to keep track of the records of how
those funds were being distributed so
that we could meet the requirements of
of the federal audit that is required on
a on a regular basis uh on how those
hobble funds are spent
um House Bill 447 actually calls for a
grant program I can tell you if we
initiate a program where we're receiving
applications for certain grants that
there is a tremendous amount of record
keeping that would go along with that
not only at the state level but the
local level so that we have the
information required to provide to the
Feds that those monies were
um
getting ready to receive another Grant
which is for security purposes primarily
but it can be used for
the other items that are appropriate to
be spent with with Hava funds
um
and you know with those Monies to the
extent that it's it is above and beyond
the base amount that we need to Cape to
keep to keep our programs running
properly then there may be opportunities
to send that money back to the cities
and towns my preference would be to do
it like we did with the pandemic funds
that would be done in a uniform way so
that the record keeping is straight
in terms of providing equipment or using
the money to provide equipment for our
local communities
in the first instance it has always been
that the municipalities of New Hampshire
have been responsible for conducting the
elections in the state
it is a local decision on whether a town
or city is going to hand count its
ballots or use a ballot counting device
um
they many of the larger towns are using
the ballot counting devices because it
saves them money
and therefore it should continue in my
opinion to be a local decision on
whether they're going to purchase those
machines or not
uh the same is true with electronic poll
books is that even though they have not
been completely approved for use in New
Hampshire they can be used as long as
they have a parallel process of
maintaining their checklist in the event
that they break down and there have been
failures of those devices elsewhere
around the country
the towns that are using them the 16
polling places that are using them find
that they are saving the town money
because it is making the lines obtaining
to obtain a ballot move faster at the
end of the night they simply have to
push a couple of buttons on the keypad
and the number of Voters that checked in
is is instant they don't have to go
through the individual pages of the mark
checklist
counting those numbers up
and then we are
finalizing the process of developing
inter an interface so that the
communities that are using the
electronic poll books can actually
upload the data that they've collected
in the poll book to our voter database
thereby saving the supervisors of the
checklist a tremendous amount of time
and effort
re-entering that data into their laptops
so there's more savings that are
realized there
the bottom line is that that the state
has been incredibly responsible using
those hobba funds in a very efficient
and effective way and I think it would
be very short-sighted if we start making
attempts to spend down that money on
one-time things putting us in danger of
reaching the point where we can't
sustain that fund because in the end uh
the taxpayers have to have to fund the
bill and if we spend down all the Hava
funds we're going to be asking for over
a million dollars every year
from the general fund
if the issue of funding equal books not
equal books but the ballot counting
devices is
urgent and important public policy
and you know it's the desire of this
committee to address that then then I
would suggest that you request those
monies from the general fund and keep
our election fund healthy to do the job
that we have been doing right along and
with that Mr chairman I'd be happy to
answer any questions questions from the
committee
representative Lane
thank you and thank you Mr secretary
um
I understand the need for conserving a
large amount of the funds but my
understanding is that this bill would
only ask for a portion say two to three
million
which is above that excess that we've
had before is that not your reading of
the bill or is there something that I'm
missing well that's the way I understand
the amendment that may be proposed I did
not read that into the bill
even so
um
I I I think that that the Secretary of
State's office and the state has managed
those funds effectively if there is an
excess in there that we determine that
we can help you know one-time program
that won't need to be sustained in the
future then we'll certainly take a look
further questions from the committee
um yes representative Hamer thank you
thank you for taking my question
are you aware that the tabulators
that we use in Manchester's 12 Wards are
on their last legs
I am aware that every accuvote counting
device is near the end of its useful
life
thank you further questions
representative Barnum
thank you Mr chairman thank you Mr
secretary I have a question about the um
the revenue and fund sources
um
so it looks like interest is what's a
revenue and also the portion of sales
Statewide checklists
is that correct is there are there any
other revenues that incorporate in that
total
those are the I'll call them the regular
Revenue sources for the election fund
when the federal government makes
additional monies available through the
help America vote act
they usually require a match of some
kind so the million dollars that is
coming available requires a 20 match
so we will come up with two hundred
thousand dollars uh from somewhere and
it may be uh other monies other state
monies that we use for technology
related to elections that we can credit
towards that but I believe we have to
pass that through the election fund so
that so that the uh so that we can make
the proper credit uh on the books for
receiving you know for making the match
requirement of those funds
further questions representative
Mr chairman uh the question on the new
machines that you're looking at now you
know what the cost will be for those
machines
my understanding is that the cost is
somewhere between six thousand and nine
thousand dollars per machine and it it
will depend on which one the battle law
Commission
approves
they may approve to I don't know that it
makes sense to approve more than that
because New Hampshire is a small market
for those machines and
the problem with the newer I won't say
the problem I mean the the technology
that comes with the newer machines is
great I mean it their digital scan
devices as opposed to Optical scan which
means that the newer devices can
actually record an image of every single
ballot that goes through
but the but the companies that make
those want to sell a a an election
system not just the machine and so we're
going to have to do some negotiating to
get what we want and not what they would
like to sell us because those additional
systems are quite a bit more expensive
follow-up follow-up and I will flag for
the committee we have to be back at one
o'clock right so if you do want to break
uh
expediency what is the I remember when
we first bought our machine in early 90s
it was 7 500 what's the current cost of
an accubo machine the last that you know
of
course uh
yeah I I really don't have a good enough
I thought it was less than that
okay
um representative Lane
uh thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
secretary again
um are there other funds available
that are coming maybe from the federal
government that might be available to
not that I am aware of sometimes the
Department of Health and Human Services
makes monies available but I'm not aware
of any current grants or offerings that
they're making
representative O'Brien
thank you I have a lot of questions I'll
try to
I went back and looked at the original
Mandate of the Hava funds from 2002 or
three when it was passed
and it was really targeting the
um the ballots that had the Punch Cards
and those one they wanted to those
replaced because of course what they had
just gone through
are states replacing machine with
electronic ballot counting machines now
is that mandate kind of expanded to
replace that and our states doing that
as a general course they're replacing
machines like this and are other states
doing that right right now
when when Java originally passed one of
the excuse me
one of the provisions uh in there was
that the states that used the punch card
ballot counting method had to replace
them New Hampshire didn't fall into that
category at the time many states had a
Statewide voter registration database
New Hampshire did not so that's where
those funds went
when some of the states
and in States outside of New England a
lot of the election organizations are
done by County not by the Secretary of
State as a as a whole but many of those
election Administration entities replace
the punch cards with
um
just uh electronic recording devices no
paper ballots and so uh you know they
perched they used the money to purchase
those and of course over time those fell
out of favor because of uh you know no
no paper receipt or paper record and so
they ended up having to replace those as
well
the short answer to your question though
is yes some states are using Java funds
follow-up
I don't know if you'll be able to answer
this but I I did the math based on all
the numbers that were being thrown out
of 9 000 machines I'm not that nine
thousand dollars per machine times 308
because I was thinking that many current
hand count towns would want to take
advantage of these funds
if they were available but that's not
really the whole picture that would that
does not include towns such as mine
Dairy I think we have eight six or eight
I can't recall ballot counting machines
Manchester I don't know how many ballot
counting machines they have so that
fee that I came up with of about three
thousand dollars would actually be much
greater when you consider towns that
would want to replace many machines
is that correct do you know how many
machines that would are online right now
for example I think I would agree with
you from the standpoint that if the
state were going to pay for the machines
that there would be towns that don't
currently have ballot counting devices
that would want them
but I think you do reach a point where
the town becomes so small that it's
still faster to count ballots by hand
you know the cost benefit just wouldn't
be there
um
and then I think the towns that
currently use them probably have the
number of ballot counting devices that
they need so I wouldn't see a large
increase
from the towns that currently have them
wanting more just because the state was
paying for it
okay I'm going to close we've we've got
to go we'll be back at one
um unless you want to recess this and
well last one
thank you and thank you for taking my
question can you clarify the amount of
java funds that are currently available
we've heard a few different numbers 12.8
11.9 12.9 I just want to make sure that
I'm
understanding where we currently stand
in the Java balance
so the number that that I have on the
spreadsheet printed from our
okay
um I have I have questions secretary
scan that I'm not going to hold the
committee with it I will announce the
question I'm going to send you in
writing and it basically expresses my
frustration with this process which is
what is taking so long with the machines
I don't want the answer now I'm going to
send it to you in writing but I think
that is kind of the Crux of this bill
and with that I'm going to close the
hearing we will be back at one o'clock
all right it's one o'clock we don't need
a quorum
as we found out earlier today
um gonna open up the hearing on House
Bill 590 allowing the removal political
advertisements containing a candidate's
name and which appear to be the
candidates advertising on public
property by the candidate uh
representative boam Committee Member
thank you Mr chairman and
honorable members of the election law
hi I'm Ralph Baum Hillsboro district 14
the town of Litchfield
this bill is fairly simple and adds to
RSA 66417 starting online
12 in the amendment
and any political advertising on public
property bearing the Canada's name and
that appears to be the candidate
advertising may be removed by the
candidate we've all seen this seen the
ads they've been around for years many
years ago in my Senate District there
was a candidate named Cruz
the weekend before the election signs
were placed directly in front of the
Canada sign
like that much with an identical looking
sign that said vote Crews you lose
despicable this past election there are
a lot of signs against Caroline Levitt
and Don bulldog and others KKK Airline
for one
signs saying the Cannons were against
before something they weren't
since these signs were made to look like
the candidate signs and after the
election if left up the candidate would
probably be blamed so this bill will
allow the Cannons to remove those signs
some people believe that the end
justifies the means
and it doesn't matter how we all talk
about Fair election this isn't fair this
bill bill will make it a waste of money
to do this false advertising and but if
not then I will be signing buying signs
next year and thank you okay will you be
taking questions yes questions from the
committee
seeing none thank you representative
foam I do not have a person but do you
need a pink card from you if you haven't
filled one out shame on you
um I don't have any other pink cards for
this bill um representative wood can you
pass me that blue sheet
well thank you okay and there was
one person signed in uh for this bill
not speaking and that person was for it
with that I am going to close the public
hearing for House Bill 590 and who knows
maybe go back to the cafeteria I'll see
okay uh it's 1 30. so we're going to
open the hearing on House Bill 387
representative wood can you please take
House Bill 387 to
the uh
Rostrum desk
um and can you introduce it and take no
questions
because you are not the sponsor and I
wouldn't ask you to talk on a bill that
you don't under that you didn't write
thank you Mr chair I like the motion uh
House Bill 387 to the floor for public
uh analysis
um this bill permits election
ballots to be you pursuant to the right
to know requests thank you
representative Woods all right uh I have
one pink card for here uh deputy
secretary Aaron Hennessey you'll be the
I don't think I have a card unless I
missed it do I get a card from the
municipal hold on to deputy secretary
with me
why don't you go ahead and why don't you
go and go and then uh we'll fill out the
nature Grace for the municipal
Association apologies I must have uh
forgotten to give you the paint card
um we uh opposed this bill uh we are
concerned about
um some of the things that I know that
the deputy secretary is going to gonna
tell you
um but realistically when it comes to
the right to know law
I know this isn't the committee that
typically handles those that's typically
Judiciary but when it comes to the right
to know law if you if you as a citizen
make a request of your municipality or
other governmental body to
um look at records They realistically
have two options they can either let you
access the original records or they can
give you a copy of those records
um in the context of ballots Our concern
would be and voted ballots are concerned
would be that if we're allowing people
access to records there is a provision
of the right to know law that they can
do things like take notes and
um and do other things which means they
will always have one of these with them
so they will always have the ability to
do something untoward uh to the ballot
so there's always the opportunity that
they could have some sort of impact on
those voted ballots obviously we have a
very sophisticated system in place that
voted ballots are sealed they're kept in
a sealed location and I'm sure the
deputy secretary can can go into great
detail about that whole process which
the legislature adopted last year to
ensure that we have those records in
case we need to do a recount and we know
that those records are kept uh in a
manner that they will that that we can
get an accurate count if we need to do a
recount
so that covers the access portion to the
to the records
and the flip side of that is the copy
option where the municipality could
provide copies of all of the ballots
um that's going to be an enormous cost
both in terms of time and money if you
think about any any election with all of
the election workers working there they
would have to access the sealed ballots
in a manner that allows them to keep
track of those make copies of those in
some Manner and provide those to purpose
of the right to know law when the
purpose as stated is to let the people
know what the government is doing so the
only thing they're going to learn from
the voted ballots is something that the
local election officials and the
Secretary of State's office have already
disclosed which is how many people in
your in your town in your ward voted for
who which they already know because we
we already did a count we did any
recounts that may have been requested
and the election results were already
certified so there's nothing here that
that would that would reveal anything
about the governmental activities
um
and so for those reasons we we oppose
that and I'm happy to answer any
questions any committee members may have
questions from the committee
representative Brennan thank you and
thank you for taking my question it's my
understanding from reading 91a and
please correct me if I'm wrong that
um 91a does not specify that only
Granite Cedars only New Hampshire
residents can file requests it's my
understanding that
um any citizen and my reading of it
would be any American citizen would be
able to file a 91a right to know request
for ballots if this bill were to be
passed into law is that correct
so there's no definition in the statute
about the word citizen
um it's possible that it only relates to
New Hampshire citizens it's possible
it's U.S citizens there's a U.S Supreme
Court case where the Supreme Court cited
91a and suggested that it meant New
Hampshire citizens of course that's the
U.S Supreme Court they don't interpret
New Hampshire law that would be the New
Hampshire Supreme Court we don't have a
ruling on that yet so I couldn't give
you a definite answer follow-up please
of course
given that there's no ruling yet on that
would it be reasonable to expect that
um someone from across the country any
someone affiliated with any group
um
would be able to make the case that they
under New Hampshire state law would be
able to file a right to no request and
would this bill given the language in
a multitude of requests from
out-of-state entities
I think that's possible I will tell you
under the existing existing law there
are frequently requests that come from
out of state which we know are from out
of state because typically they're
companies asking for typically Planning
and Zoning records because they package
those up and resell those so those
frequently come from companies in
Florida and California elsewhere
uh it uh it obviously would be the case
that anyone anywhere could could make
that type of request and then it would
be a question of how we respond to it
and what type of litigation what's the
cost of that litigation the results from
that
thank you can I just have one more
follow-up yes
our municipalities currently
um
let me rephrase
are there some municipalities that
struggle to fulfill 91a requests at this
time is there a struggle that
municipalities face yes so they're all
required to respond to 91a requests the
issue comes when you have of what I
would call voluminous requests which
means that they're asking if the
requester is asking for a large volume
of Records so typically you see this in
the context of you know they request all
the emails to and from the Town
Administrator for the last six months
that's a huge volume that has to be
captured it has to be soared through
anything that's you know going to have
private information is going to have to
be redacted removed from those records
before it's handed over that those type
of undertakings typically result in the
town hiring and ex usually their Law
Firm to come in and do that that's
obviously in the cost of tens of
thousands of dollars and municipalities
do see this on a pretty frequent basis
so there is a definite struggle there if
you're looking at something
that's going to be comparative
comparable in terms of volume of the
type of Records you're going through
obviously this is a little bit different
because it's ballots but still someone's
gonna have to go through and copy each
one of those
and somehow annotate it in a way that
they are going to understand you know
I've already copied that box I need to
move to this box that which is just
going to be a logistical headache one
more it's fun
would ballots requesting to view all
ballots be considered a voluminous
request for
c1a
I use the term voluminous request that's
not in the statute I would consider it a
voluminous request but I don't know that
everyone would agree with me on that one
okay thank you thank you I'm going to
have you sit down we're going to bring
you back we're not done with you yet the
sponsor is here so we'll get the sponsor
and sponsor intent for this bill and
then we'll bring you back up if that's
okay
welcome to election law thank you sorry
trained to be in two places at the same
time for two different Bill hearings
um
representative hole serving the towns of
Dunbarton Hooksett Allentown and epsom
here on behalf of House Bill 387 right
permitting ballots to be viewed under a
right to no request current law
prohibits ballots and and certain
materials from being seen by anybody
other than those who show up at a
recount
then through lots of recounts Dunbarton
still hand counts their ballots so I see
lots of ballots every election cycle as
long as I'm not on the ballot
this is different than there's a there
was a similar Bill heard by this
committee recently relative to ballots
being accessed this is slightly
different and I'm going to highlight
a ballot
assuming it's an at some level is
anonymous right there's a bunch of
checked boxes okay it doesn't
necessarily describe who filled it out
how it was filled out how they how the
person voted however canceled and uncast
ballots
right rejected
um absentee ballots a bunch of these
actually have confidential information
because there's a name somehow tied to
this short list of of ballots right
ballots that are in the box that have
been cast that weren't challenged okay
um are effectively Anonymous data
that's different than the ones that I
highlighted and left so I basically said
make all the ones that are Anonymous
data available to the public and the
benefit to this is
um we already have machines that scan
these they do some work for calculating
and and tabulating votes as well but
high speed scanners are readily
available technology is off the shelf
and the benefit to scanning and
Publishing the original data and making
it available if someone comes in with a
right to know request
is anybody can go verify that their
ballot was counted they know what the
pattern was they may have done check
marks all the way down and then one
looked more like an X so they can look
through that file and say yep I see my
ballot was in there and when I added up
all the ones for my race or this other
race that I was concerned about I see
it's not hard to start thinking about
storing this data long term anyway we
store a lot most of the world is moving
to storing electronic files if we have
them in electronic files there's no
reason why the PDFs couldn't be
available under a simple right to know
request
I do think we have to pay attention to
the list of ballots that I mentioned in
21-25
because those are no longer
Anonymous level data
um you could actually try and figure out
based on a absentee ballot that wasn't
turned in that arrives at the town
clerk's office too late if that's
available someone can open it up and
know well so John Smith over here voted
this way because I saw his ballot and I
saw it tied to the name I don't ever
want to allow that to happen I don't
ever want to I want to keep voting
so but there's no reason why we can't
see the rest of the the ballots and for
them for those who run the run the
ballots through the machines already
we're used to this being a stack of
ballots we're used to those who go to
recount seeing everybody's ballot
the only difference between those who
request a recount and and the rest of
the state in terms of ballot exposure is
someone didn't ask for a recount if
literally you could make a hundred
percent of the ballots available
tomorrow without a right to know request
it's a next election by requesting a
recount in every state rep race and the
same thing would take place all that
um
I don't think it's overly burnism I
think we're going to be moving in the
direction long term of having some sort
of machine that scans these anyway and
at that point the PDF file is available
and If the town clerk needs to release
the PDF file it's a it's literally email
the PDF file out there's no reason why
we can't scan the ballots fully the
night of the election and storm
digitally
with that um
I'll close my testimony and answer any
questions if there are any I am sure
there will be questions questions from
the committee
uh representative weary
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking the time to answer the question
um
so about I think half the towns do hand
cans now
um what provision would you see for
uh tabulating right using that word uh
counting those uh hand count towns
so so I believe there we have funds
remaining in one of the federal grants
for running elections and election
Integrity there's no reason why we
couldn't provide to each of the towns a
high-speed scanner capable of the town
clerk scanning the file after the
election and making right scan images
available just like you would for any
almost any other right to know request
is is typically done electronically as
opposed to physical paper copies
take a follow-up
okay
further questions from the committee
representative Brennan thank you and
thank you for taking my question
um
prior to drafting this bill or
requesting this bill be drafted did you
happen to consult with any Town clerks
about
um the ballot handling process or about
um
filling 91a requests and how that works
through
municipal offices
I did talk about making the public I did
talk with several Town clerks and
supervisors of the checklist about
making the ballots public right that and
they agreed that that is the best
insurance way to make sure that we have
integrity in our elections
as an engineer right I always look at
like looking at the original data and
the best way to show that our system
works is to publish the original data
um now in terms of the process on
Election night where they collect all
the ballots they put them in the boxes
they sealed the boxes up with the
special tape they sign and autograph
everything and then they go into some
Vault you can't do it right you can't
then necessarily go back the day after
and open those boxes back up what you're
going to want to do is scan the ballots
on the way into the boxes so the images
are available
follow up please yep
are you aware that currently our
um ballot counting machines do not have
digital scanning and that the machines
that we are considering for the future
purchase may have that capability but
there's no guarantee that every
municipality would have those machines
or high-speed scanning machines
for any purpose that would be able to
fulfill what is outlined in this bill
so yes the current machines
are tabulating machines they are not
high speed scanning Right image storage
devices I agree with you there future
machines will have that inherent
Hardware that's how the machines will
work and then they will use software to
digitally figure out how the votes are
tabulated
so it is possible in the future machines
to have them just publish a copy of the
image now I'm not sure what machines the
Secretary of State's office is looking
at but high-speed scanning technology is
readily available okay and depending on
on the size and scope and cost of the
machine it runs from hundreds of images
per minute to thousands of images per
minute these machines are very capable I
don't think we're going to go buy a 500
000 high-speed image scanner for every
town but they do have machines that are
set up to scan thousands of images in
I think what we would want to do is
outfit outfit each town with one of
these and as part of the process go
ahead and before the the ballots go into
the box scan the whole thing and store
I don't see a fiscal note attached to
this bill
um so
who and how are we paying for the
high-speed scanning devices for every
municipality and who is paying for the
cost of
the election workers time in scanning
all of this as well who's responsible
for those costs
and so
um typically legislators don't craft the
financial notes like various departments
is do that
um
and I'm not sure why this one doesn't
have a fiscal note of any sort
we do I do believe there are still money
retained or remaining in some of the
federal grants under the Secretary of
State for election Integrity that we
could use to cover the cost of Hardware
one more follow-up please please you
know you know not the question you know
not the statement you just paid
representative
what follow-up this bill has an
effective date 60 days after passage so
I'm just wondering where
where are we coming up with the funding
for these municipalities within those 60
days after passage If This Were to
succeed in every step along the way
so am I correct that there was a pool of
money for election integrity at one
point
this goes back at least two years ago
maybe it's maybe it's been depleted but
I thought there were several million
dollars set aside
for election Integrity related issues
I I couldn't tell you that very much I
just I pray to God not referring to have
a funds because I just we just sat
through that for a while so okay
um and in reference to the 60 days right
the next election is quite a ways out
this bill isn't likely to pass before
um the midterm sorry the Municipal
elections this fall so what we're
talking about is potentially City
elections in November and or the
would you like a follow-up
representative like here look like the
gears are turning
so this bill is based on the premise
that we're going to have new ballot
counting machines prior to 2024 that is
some way shape or form
um
I'm sorry I'm just trying to wrap my
head around this can you just explain
where the funding is coming from and how
this could possibly
um be enacted 60 days after passage or
by 2024. I believe the representative
just spoke to the funding whether or not
the answer was acceptable to you or not
is is fine uh the the question about the
implementation speed is valid so I will
allow that forward thank you
so
because 60 days to implement this
doesn't mean that there's an election on
day 61. the next elections that this
would have to be in place for are either
the likely elections of November this
year which is six months out or at least
four months after the bill potentially
could be signed into law assuming it's
in the July time frame and then the
subsequent elections in 2024.
um high-speed scanning devices start
about a thousand dollars and they work
up depending on the throughput you need
um some of the ones are significantly
more expensive but you don't need
twenty five thousand dollar scanner for
a town of a thousand people when you can
do it in 10 minutes using something that
does
whatever 20 50 pages a minute
are there questions from the committee
Juju
who is going to pay for
the staff
and the time
that staff is going to take
for all of these 91a requests that will
so if the ballots are available and are
ready scanned I'm going to answer this
in two parts right on Election night
prior to the ballots being put into the
boxes and sealed and stored if that if
those documents are scanned ahead of
time
the 91 91a request is relatively simple
it's send them a copy of the file this
is not a difficult task or a significant
amount of time
in terms of what takes place that night
currently Town clerks spend a lot of
time especially in hand counted talents
double checking their math making sure
that the overvotes the undervotes all
the list goes on you guys are much more
aware of it than I am
all of those boxes are checked and all
of those things are tabulated I've sat
at tables with another person right in
Dunbarton every election cycle counting
ballots
if long term you could do the the effort
of scanning these and and allowing them
to be under a 91a we could start to cut
back on some of those those additional
requests we've made of the Town clerks
make it even easier to get the counting
done right they do the counting they
count all the offices they scan them and
they they release them and then if
someone wants to go look to see whether
there was a bunch of undervotes or
overvotes or all the other things that
we look for
um they could do that on their own time
further questions from the community
representative
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative hole for taking my
question
I'm been reading line 17 through 21 on
page one
a question relates to those lines those
two sentences there the first reads
ballots shall not be exempt from the
provisions of RS 91a that's
understandable yep next sentence
uh beginning in the last quarter of line
19 says this exemption this exemption
shall apply to any ballots or absentee
voter affidavits
uh maybe I'm reading this wrong but it
seems that this exemption shall apply to
any ballots how does it not contradict
the first sentence starting on line 17.
so I think the exemption and goes to
um
where is it there was a section in
there was a section in law about them
right about 91a and I think it's a
different section of law relative to
what is allowed under 91a and not and
ballots are Exempted under that section
right so this was an exemption statute
right but the first sentence yes I'm
sorry Mr chairman follow up please
all right but
uh the first sentence says ballot shall
not be exempt from the provisions of 91a
and the next sentence says this
exemption this exemption shall apply to
any ballots oh I see what you're saying
the any ballots comment yeah a fair
point that might be a drafting thing
that came out of OLS we were trying to
deal with canceled and uncast ballots
right versus the generic ballots
okay thank you
um I can take one more I have a two
o'clock all right hey look at that all
right uh you may not even get one more
or any further oh yep rips the mirror
it's not gonna let you out of there I'm
gonna defer to burn all right
representative
uh thank you Mr chairman
I'm in this bill it is not in this bill
right it is the easiest way to deal with
making the balance available instead of
handing
um someone who comes into the town
office the stack of sealed boxes what
you do is you scan them on the way into
the skilled boxes and then those images
are available later on for a 91a
up please uh does it we have time for
follow yeah yes it's just reliability to
the same thing so really this is really
determining on the equipment at the time
of Elections is that correct it is
determined upon that you would you to do
you could implement this now right and
if you saw an abundance of people asking
for requests for 91a buy the next
election cycle you would want to make
sure the machines are in place to do
this
thank you all right is that it for you
thank you representative we'll bring the
HMA back up so we can keep going
grilling on him and move on May I have
one comment it's your testimony so yeah
uh notwithstanding any prior testimony
that I may have given today uh I would
not support any effort to uh use Hava
funds to to purchase high-speed scanners
for the purpose of scanning devices
because I don't see how that helps
anyone vote
happy to take questions okay are there
questions from the committee uh I I
probably I will have some so if someone
wants to get in before I do go for it
um
so your testimony that was interrupted
uh concern was I just want to kind of
recap the municipal association's
concerns so you have concerns about
um
the cost or who's going to pay for the
staff time or the scanner or whatever so
you've cost about that
um and then you had
um you had one other question I'm asking
my own follow-up here but you another
concern about the potential of tampering
potential tampering of balance but if
it's after the election has been
certified and all the legal challenges
are done
well that's a good question uh I I would
say that
generally speaking we are
keeping the ballots
or the period specified in in the
statute and then disposing them as such
or the purpose of whether they need to
be recounted or whether further action
needs to be taken and that's why we're
preserving them in the sealed containers
and so that's why I think we would care
about them
okay
um
so you're you're saying that we care
about them because the federal
government requires us to keep for 22
months so that's why we care about them
yes okay
um so my last question is so let's say
the the money
question disappears and
um the it's after the election so
nothing can change even if they find the
most horrendous counting known to man
at that point does the association have
any concerns if those two things are
alleviated we find a magical way that
the magical Money Tree pays for
everything
um and the and the elections cannot be
changed what are the concerns does the
municipal Association have at that point
well if the magical Money Tree is paying
for all the staff time is paying for uh
you know the scanning or whatever copy
needs to occur and on that point I just
want to add that um the uh New Hampshire
Supreme Court has ruled in a couple
cases uh Taylor versus SAU 55 and green
versus SAU 55 and those are from around
um that electronic records are the ones
that have to be reduced electronically
everything else is you know paper
records are produced paper copies
they're not they don't have to be
scanned and emailed
um so you know but if they're the
magical money tree has paid for
everything
um then we're not really concerned
because it's paying for the costs of all
of this production and all of this this
uh this effort going into it
um
that's that really covers the scope of
our production uh concerns okay I think
that that was the only question
my stutter's kicking in representative
Brennan thank you thank you for taking
my question
um in Reading 91a there are Provisions
Beyond copying that a person might be
able to
access a requested document including
photographing or videoing
um with technology being what it is now
does the municipal Association have any
concerns about the Integrity
um of our ballots
given that anyone with an iPhone could
take a picture of however many ballots
and manipulate that with
a free easy to use
you know photo app
um are there any questions about the
trust in our elections or the Integrity
of our ballots with that potential for
manipulation
so we really have policies relating to
the process and those all go towards
ensuring that the election occur goes
smoothly and the count is accurate
and that builds into the election
Integrity what I think the secretary of
state would be better positioned to
answer your question thank you fair
enough are any uh representative wood
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um if we if we looked at phasing this in
as we get the new equipment it seems to
me that we're going to have this digital
record we're going to have this argument
coming down the line that data sitting
around for 22 months nobody looking at
is is not not what I I Envision going
forward if we phase this in if this had
a a amendment to phase it in so that
would basically talking about data that
comes from the free from these machines
some management would that be would that
have the same concern I understand you
can what your concerned you said before
so are there a couple things that I want
to raise that I I don't know the answer
to
um first I have no idea what the new
machines are capable of what
capabilities they are I'm sure the
Secretary of State could could answer
those questions for you with the
different vendors
um and then
you know as far as having essentially a
data file a basically a a long PDF with
different ballots on on each
um
a different ballot on each page
um you're only going to have that
four machine counted ballots you're not
going to have that in the 113
locations where their hand counts you're
not going to have that for any of the
affidavit ballots that occur where
someone comes and registers for the
first time without any paperwork and
they have to put their battle in the
side pocket
so you will you may end up with the
perception of saying hey we've you know
who's conquered this example because we
use machines here
um we you know they release uh these a
PDF for each Ward and someone goes
through and adds those up but that's not
going to be the total number of ballots
that are actually counted because you
have a whole bunch that went in the side
pocket that were hand counted that were
tabulated in as part of the the
paperwork that sent to the Secretary of
State's office that's part of the vote
count so you do risk the possibility of
having not captured every ballot and
that
May impinge upon people's belief about
uh whether the the count was valid or
not
any further questions from the committee
okay thank you thank you now we will
take deputy secretary Hennessey
foreign
members of the committee Aaron Hennessey
deputy secretary of state and although I
really appreciate a representative Woods
introduction of the bill I'm glad to
have heard from the sponsor to get an
understanding of what he was aiming
towards so
um last week this committee heard house
bill
415 which pointing out again didn't have
an FN but should have
um and and I testified for a significant
amount of time on that one and um and I
apologize I should have said we are in
opposed to the we are opposed to this
bill
um I'm going to do the same today and I
apologize for shifting around but I
think I want to first start out
at the language of the bill I know this
committee likes to look at the words and
what they mean and how they're
structured and we did this earlier today
but
um to represent quaily's point
when you look at the language on lines
1920 actually that whole paragraph it
says ballots shall not be exempt from
the provisions of RSA 91a
and then it refers to the exemption
so I'm not quite sure there does appear
to be some sort of drafting era but in
that same
next um sentence there it says the
exemption shall apply to any ballots or
absentee voter affidavits prepared for
or used in an election conducted by the
state or any political subdivision
including Federal elections so prepared
for or used in is all election materials
so it's all um it's all ballots that
were not actually used so those have
been prepared for an election and the
ones used in were the ones that someone
cast a ballot on or spoiled or anything
like that
um and then the rest of that sentence
says that it applies to State elections
Federal elections and your local
municipality Municipal elections and
then the next new sentence canceled and
uncast ballots and successfully
challenged and rejected
absentee ballots
still contained in their envelopes
repaired blah blah shall be exempt from
RSA 91a so then it says canceled and on
cast ballots are exempt from 91a but it
doesn't refer back to affidavits or any
of the other envelopes or any of the
other election materials prepared for an
election
so going back to the last bill last week
HP 415 where I testified that there's
outer envelopes there's innum envelopes
there's AF there's the mailing envelopes
there's the affidavit envelopes or
somebody has to sign
my reading of this is those materials
would have to be scanned as well if
somebody wants to have an have a right
to know request but then getting to a
lot of your questions about the scanning
part of this bill nothing in this bill
mentions a scanner nothing mentions the
option of an electronic record if an
electronic record is available under 91a
then you can give them that information
electronically but if it's not available
then you have to make the paper those
paper ballots
available
you turn over to the next page
it talks about how a clerk has to store
the ballots and last year this committee
and the senate committee
and the full legislative bodies agreed
that our ballots should be stored and
there should be a log kept it should be
stored in a locked area whether a filing
cabinet or wherever it however the
municipality decides but needs to be
locked and there needs to be a log kept
of who goes in and out
so the the language in this bill allows
for
um someone
um to access that locked location
so um it's talking about the ballots so
once stored the containers shall be
accessible only to individuals working
under the direct direction of the town
clerk as required for recounts by a
person filing a right to no request
under 91a or is necessary for the
Secretary of State to verify the store
the container storage so this language
in here has nothing to do with scanning
as we heard a lot of testimony about it
someone who files a right to know
request the way this is written can go
into that Lock storage area and look at
the balance that's what access this this
bill gives them
so that was my testimony about the
language of the bill where there's
inconsistencies and and again now no
mention of scanning
um
so now I'm going to just chit chat about
why we don't like the building otherwise
so other than all the conflicting
language there's the time constraints
mentioned by representative Brennan this
there's no
um there's nothing in the language of
this bill that says this applies to only
future elections so 60 days after this
bill were to be signed into law someone
can go into any of your town or city
clerk's offices and again I would
recommend reaching out to them to get
their opinion on this bill and they
would have to grant them access to their
locked storage container where they've
kept their 2022 ballots
um
and uh it wouldn't apply to this
Municipal elections in March but
depending on when you have your
Minnesota elections it could apply to
those as well
um
so again the ballots are not currently
scanned nor all the election other other
election materials scanned so you would
give this person and anyone perhaps from
out of state access to your physical
ballots
just imagine a amount of time that it
will take for your local election
officials but also for the state to if
we have any boxes that we've done
recounts on and just a reminder we had a
record recount period and for our
November elections
um
the the law doesn't consider any of the
other laws that would need to be changed
related to changing of this and that if
you I don't know
um who requested it but there's a good
memo over here on the table written by
your committee researcher and it goes
into affidavits and other Natures of the
91 a laws but anything related to access
of ballots anything related to
affidavits personal information those
laws would have to be changed as well
um in um
some testimony related to that this bill
was so that people can have confidence
in our elections but to representative
Woods question and the municipal
associations testimony
um
not every ballot is going to be scanned
by our new scanners when we get them
there's going to be the hand count
balance there's going to be all the
other information that needs to be
scanned so there's if anything this
might cause more questions to come up
um if somebody's trying to recalculate
an election to see if that really the
results really were how
um your town or your ward said they were
or if have the recount ended up there's
going to be ballots that once we do have
our new devices that are not scanned so
there's going to be questions that come
up from that
at our last hearing related to 415
somebody asked me to look into the
Vermont law I did reach out to Vermont I
haven't heard back on what their access
to balance is but looking just my
Googling and again it's
not necessarily actual law but
um they do provide access to ballots but
it's after the from what I can read and
I'm still waiting for their legal
opinion it's after the public storage
information time frame has ended so
nobody can make any changes accidentally
or on purpose to the physical ballots
during the recount time frame or to the
22-month time frame again I'm trying to
I'm still waiting to hear back from them
on that
uh jumping around again I'm sorry the
history of the 2013 law change
um that put ballots in the 91a exemption
category
um for my discussions with secretary
Scanlon who was in had just started in
my position that time but was previously
in the in the legislature that had to
um pass bills related to help America
vote act um ballots were although they
were not exempt from 91a previously
they were not ever open to the public
they were not public access documents
before so this
um putting them in as an exemption to
91ma make sure that they wouldn't have
Public Access so even though the law
went into effect at that time frame it
didn't actually change any of the
policies in New Hampshire
um
I just want to reiterate that any of my
testimony that I said for the reasons we
were opposed to 415 applies to this bill
too and I'm happy to take questions okay
representative Bruno Brian thank you Mr
chairman
as this is written I think you you
mentioned there's nothing in here about
creating an image
would this mean that some communities
would interpret this to mean they don't
need to create an image some would think
they should and then there would be an
in
the things would be n equal if you were
one person one town was trying to get
information they wouldn't
they'd find it differently and
that that could be thank you thank you
for the question so
um this the same and again I'm not a
lawyer
um I'm sure there's somebody here though
that is but
um this is 91a does not require you to
create a an electronic image of
something but if you have it already
then you are supposed to give that if
that's the way they requested the the
um the information so if a town does not
have a ballot scanner or a high speed
scanner of any sort they are not going
to be able to provide an electronic
image somebody that does have one has
the option of running their ballots
through according
to the testimony we heard previously not
according to the language of the bill
um so there would be inconsistency on
how the information is given out if
somebody requested 91a from every single
um municipality in the state for ballots
further questions
uh I do a follow-up representative yes
I'd like a follow-up thank you Mr
chairman
uh I also did a little math so if every
community in the state
asked for uh help obtaining financial
help obtaining these scanners
would that fall under help America vote
act funding and that'd be appropriate
use of those funds for three hundred and
thank you for the question
um
I would have to look into that I I know
that if you were to use a ballot
counting device that it would but I
don't know that if you were to purchase
scanning equipment for the purpose of
91a that it would
but I will get that information to you
further questions representative Byrne
do you have a question yes thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question so ballots obviously come in
various sizes
um we've talked about this before with
another bill as far as page sizes so
that um costs would also be involved in
the 91a on these ballots as well as the
time now usually what I understand is
the 91a is paid for by the person
no the chairman is shaking his head um
if you were to if you were to ask anyone
who has respond in my opinion
if you were to ask anyone that is has to
respond to a 91a request there are
limitations on the charges that they can
charge for a response to a 91a request
and that those limitations
do not cover the cost
of a lot of requests
follow-up yes so this is just
hypothetical because obviously we don't
have image scanners at the moment that
are taking pictures but if we did
in the upcoming years
um and we had future machines that could
um immediately scan the ballot as it was
tabulating and Counting
and be saved
to some drive that would be available
that would reduce the cost of the
request
um
which would be affordable by the person
requesting the 91a would that be a
feasible
change to the 91a request for these
ballots
thank you for the good question I think
that when we get to that point in time a
couple years from now when communities
do have highs I have ballot scanning
devices
um that that would be a much better time
for the legislature to look at this bill
or a bill similar to this to see
if it's a better
a better option at that point but to
earlier testimony that that does not
help half of our municipalities right
now that do not have ballot scanning
devices
and I just want to remind people even if
a ballot scanning device was provided to
a location there are annual maintenance
fees related to that it's not just a
one-time cost
further questions uh representative
Muirhead thank you
um
I have a question about the length of
time we're required to store ballots so
I understand Federal elections according
to 33a3a
it's 22 months for non-federal elections
is just 60 days
thank you for the good legal question my
understanding is yes it's 60 days and 22
for federal however if there is
legal action pending then you have to
you can't destroy them so
further questions representative Brennan
thank you and thank you for taking my
question the prime sponsor spoke about
a scenario where
a voter might pursue 91a requests for
ballots sift through those ballots to
try and find their own personal ballot
based on the way that they filled out
that ballot
given that scenario
um
and I remember from other testimony
about ballot marks and whatnot
um
would that type of scenario become more
common among voters like would this
invite voters to make unusual marks on
their ballots so that someone could so
they could identify their own ballot if
they were trying to confirm whether or
thank you for the question
yes perhaps that could happen yeah I
um but I just want to remind people that
sometimes people sign their ballot and
put their name on it and do other
identifying things so there's also the
secrecy issue that might come up follow
up please follow up so would the
Secretary of State's office be concerned
about voter integrity and confidence and
Trust in our elections if ballots were
made available
to any
American citizen that filed a right to
know request given that
someone that more people might make
so thank you for the question I think I
think that we would have two concerns
one being that
it could invite ballot purchasing
schemes which would could be
intricate at that point
um but also that you could lose your pro
further questions
um
I have some
um relating to ballot privacy how can
that be a concern of yours when we allow
people to take pictures of ballots
during recounts
that's a good question
um follow for follow-up or not even
follow up with different question what
is the purpose of keeping these ballots
if they're not
to be made available like we're just
paying for 22 months of storage so like
why even store them if we can't look at
them
I'm not quite sure what what the federal
guideline of 22 months the history
behind that bike but I can get that for
you and the last one is
um we did a recount or I shouldn't say
this is not this is the the Royal the
Royal we not the personal way but there
was a recount conducted uh for state
senate this last time that was outside
the three percent margin
um what was the cost of that and who
paid for it
thank you for the question
um
the
cost of that
was in the thousands and I believe
most most of the cost of that was paid
for by the person requesting the recount
thank you
um any other questions would you like
the exact details on it okay I'm more
concerned who paid for it
um that's it I think unless somebody
else has their their point of questions
they'd like to ask representative weary
so uh thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking the question so the sponsor
talked about really the intent being
um for the review of anonymous
data
if if
the magical Money Tree exists and
scanners for everybody and that sort of
thing does the Secretary of State's
office have any objections to the
thank you for the question so that
I'm not quite sure I understand the
anonymous data point
um but
I do want to say that we for voter
confidence we do do post-election audits
now we started in uh in the primary we
did two locations we did four in the
general election there's a bill that's
passed the Senate to make those continue
into the future without an end date and
there's more audits that we would have
to do in the general election
um so to the point of
voter confidence that they're that the
sponsor spoke to about their vote being
counted
um I think that would help a voter to
um have more confidence that when they
cast their ballot it was actually
counted by the machine
especially since there's a different
type of machine that's doing the
counting then it's doing the counting
locally
for the questions all right I think
we're done with your deputy secretary
thank you uh we did have one more pink
card come in after you uh you started
speaking as every Secretary of
is that the 415 Amendment it is we
already have that oh okay well you got
um thank you honorable members for the
record my name is Ellen Reed I represent
rockinghamton that's New Market in new
Fields
um and I did just pass out that language
only because so many of the language the
language section is identical to this
current bill and so many of the
questions that have come up so far
um are answered by the language and most
of the language just for full disclosure
comes from my personal
um introduction of the bill well 2018 I
introduced HB 1520 and then 2019 I
introduced another one the number
escapes me but it was nearly identical
language and so most of the language in
the amendment that I just sent around
um is from those previous iterations
obviously before 2020 and all of that so
as you know from my testimony on HP 415
I am in support of the concept of
transparency and restoring 901a
access to to to cast vote records or
cast ballots so a few points that were
brought up Supreme Court decision so
obviously Supreme this was challenged
the idea of it being exempt the Supreme
Court said that it was constitutional
and that doesn't mean you have to hold
on to I mean that's all the work that we
do right is changing law that ostensibly
is constitutional so just because the
Supreme Court said that something is
constitutional doesn't mean that you
shouldn't change the law it just means
that they can't Strike It Down
um so I just want to be very clear about
that because there was some like well
how dare we overturn a Supreme Court
ruling it doesn't overturn the ruling it
simply changes
one constitutional law to a different
constitutional law
um there is problematic language in this
particular iteration of this bill as was
brought up like I said all of those
questions are fixed I believe are fixed
quite adequately in the language that I
sent around
um for example the time to request 91a
access to cast ballots is after the
recount period has closed
done you don't have any more concern
about well are you just doing this to
overturn election results and integrity
oops
so um just very briefly some of the
other issues and I do want to point out
so the language separating out the idea
of digital image from from actual
physical ballots
um I think it's important to separate
those two out the digital images are to
the extent they exist are already
available under 91a and in fact the
Department of Justice Federal Department
of Justice released language two years
ago saying that that had to be kept as
part of that 22-month period so even if
it's a digital image and in some cases
those those digital images are used for
the purposes of counting
um my language says here that if someone
uses an accessible system I understand
the accessible systems now generate
identical ballots to the rest of the
ballots but if somebody does use an
accessible system the moderators shall
have two other people use the same
accessible system so those ballots are
now
removed from any personal information
similarly any ballot that has an
identical identifiable marking on it or
about any absentee ballot that's the
only absentee ballot in a Precinct those
are removed from access as well those
are Exempted
um
as this bill also sets out a very
detailed process for making sure that
the security of the ballots is
maintained by the town while still
giving access to that viewing service so
I'm happy I guess to answer any
questions
um but I didn't want to get too much
into like literally an amendment on a
different bill but it's so many of the
same questions have come up that I
wanted to kind of bring that to the
committee's attention
procedurally so the Committees where
um we have to discuss the bills that's
in front of us we don't have an
amendment for this bill in front of us
we will be discussing 415 today during
executive session so if you do have any
questions I am going to limit them to
the scope of the actual bill on the
table
well that was easy made my disclaimer
stop that all right thank you so much
um representative wood can I grab the
and then
two it's almost 2 30 representative
Elaine I will recess briefly mostly
yes yes okay uh the blue sheet is uh
blank so with that I will bring to close
uh the public hearing on HP 387 the
committee will stand in recess for 10
okay
there are people here what all right
I think it's better
over there
yeah
it's actually checks checks the pressure
in each one they're all down about us
and six or seven pounds so it's not a
week
I find that happens sometimes I've
noticed that the five Chief is
and then after I get the oil change and
whatnot I find it I have to level like
it's supposed to be at 32. the four of
all right
um next so if
which was always the plan
um we have two days left to complete our
work
so anticipate next Tuesday it should be
a quite long day
probably what I'll do is take all of the
bills that we have had public hearings
on and not exact and put them all up and
we'll just chug through as many as we
can
all right let's open the executive
session on House Bill 40 representative
Barry I am if house bill 40b inexp into
legislate
is there a second second
very boom
which is kind of fun to say
it's like speak to emotion uh I'll do it
on the OTP
wait what
we'll do it on the next motion I'm all
set
any discussion from the committee
thank you so much uh clerk will call the
roll the motion is ICL on House built
40. representative Berry yes
representative prudhome O'Brien yes
representative boom yes
representative qualey yes
representative
um
Boyd Boyd
yes
representative Burnham yes
representative Kennedy
representative wood yes
representative lean no
representative Ward no
representative Hamer no
representative Hamlet no
representative weirhead
representative Lamontagne
uh no
sorry
representative Brennan no
representative Grill no representative
Howard no
representative Schultz no
and representative Smith yes
all right
um
representative Lane
may I make a motion at this point sure
make a motion ought to pass
representative Lane moves ought to pass
do you want to speak to your emotion
and the clerk's ready she'll call the
roll
it's an option pass on House Bill 40.
representative Berry no
representative predom O'Brien no
representative boehm
representative quaali oh
representative Boyd no
representative Burnham no
representative Kennedy
representative wary
representative wood no
representative Lane yes
representative Ward yes
representative Hamer yes
representative Hamlet yes
representative weirhead
representative LaMontagne yes
representative Brennan yes
representative Grill yes representative
Howard yes
and representative Schultz yes
and representative Smith no
all right so by the end of today I'll
have a report from Representatives Barry
today
yeah I'll do my best the the It's gotta
be today
the deadline's noon tomorrow
so I'm happy to write it for you
representative everything that the
here you can email them to me but once
we get past today I either don't submit
them or write it myself
and that closes the executive session on
open the executive session on House Bill
this executive session is recessed until
yeah and with a number of people that
are requesting room scheduling Tuesdays
all right ready
open executive session on House Bill 286
representative purdom O'Brien's
recognized promotion
I move ought to pass
this is a a simple bipartisan bill that
um
allows political committees or a
candidates can member of a candidate's
campaign to re retrieve campaign items
such as signs I've been in the position
of of needing that done I think we've
all
been there and uh it's not controversial
in any way and this is a good
housekeeping bill
I support it
further discussion on the bill
okay
motions ought to pass on House Bill 286
whenever the clerk's ready
representative Berry yes
representative prudhome O'Brien yes
representative Bohm yes
representative qualey yes
representative Boyd yes
representative Kennedy
representative weary
representative wood
representative lean yes
representative Ward yes
representative Hamer yes
representative Hamlet yes
representative
representative LaMontagne yes
representative Brennan yes
representative Grill yes representative
Howard yes
representative Schultz yes
representative Smith
yes
22-0
any objection to consent
all right consensus
open executive session on House Bill 316
and recessed it to March 14th at 10 A.M
I really should have brought the gobble
open the executive session on House Bill
402 and recess it to March 14th at 10
A.M
well it needs a hearing yeah
yes which has been scheduled for next
Tuesday
we'll open the executive session on
House Bill 405 representative Barry is
recognized for motion uh yes I remember
the house bill 405 be in expedient to
would you like to speak to emotion no
further discussion on the bill
all right then
efficient as always
right on time
um
representative Barry yes
representative purdom O'Brien yes
representative Bohm yes
representative qualey yes
representative Boyd yes
representative Burnham yes
representative Kennedy
representative weary
representative wood
representative lean
yes
representative Ward yes
representative Hamer yes
representative Hamlet yes
representative weirhead
representative LaMontagne yes
representative Brennan yes
representative Grill yes representative
Howard yes
representative Schultz yes
and representative Smith yes
another
20-0
any objection to consent
okay consent it goes that closes the
executive session on 405.
we'll open the executive session on
House Bill 415 representative where he's
recognized for a motion
so there's a
pass representative weary moves ought to
pass is there a second second
turn on your microphone
microphone
uh yes Mr chairman the committee I
believe
um I believe representative weary is
2023-0703 H representative weary moves
rep Amendment
would you like to speak to your emotion
on the amendment
yes
um
uh so
House Bill 415 is similar to previous
bills that have been submitted and
representative Reed was uh generously
submitted this amendment with a
correcting a number of the issues that
are
I believe everyone has a copy of this
and
I I think it addressed a number of the
issues that were raised during the
[Music]
received it recently no
okay
yeah
we're an executive session so
we don't take testimony during
Executives
um I have a parliamentary inquiry yep
the um House Bill 415 and House Bill 387
are substantially similar dealing with
same subject in fact the same lines of
the RSA so could anything that we look
at for 5 4 15 4 could we also look at
387 not at the same time obviously we
talk one bill at a time but would that
be procedurally allowable
so you're asking can we talk about
387 well I I guess the bills are the
bills are so similar not that we could
talk about them at the same time
but it in theory these these bills they
deal with the same section of RSA so
like what would be the process of
hypothetically changing the amendment uh
from 415 to 387 after this executive
session would it be relatively easy
I understand we have an exact 387 yet
right so correct
so you're trying to make the argument
the amendment will work better on that
bill uh I I believe it would and allows
more time to work on the subject as a
whole we could talk about 415 today
anything we wanted to do in theory we
could do to 387.
okay it's kind of thin ice but as long
as the discussion is on the amendment
and where it belongs so you're basically
trying to all of you if you're going to
discuss this argue that you don't want
the amendment because you think it
belongs on another bill correct
all right we can do that
thank you just check my lunch from the
clerk later yeah you know it's it's nice
out and I wouldn't snowmobiling this
weekend so I'm down to skating on some
um you know I may speak to for the
amendment you may speak to the amendment
um the amendment gets really close to I
think where we need to be on the
underlying issue
um I would like more time to work on it
um we got the amendment this morning
which is not enough time to review it
but we did hear and testimony from 415
um that you know certain things like
who's going to pay for what would you
when you can access it
um I find it
the arguments about not making these
ballots public documents is thin no no
thin ice uh pun there just they're just
thin
um but I think we have some opportunity
to take the good language here in 415
um continue to work on it with the bill
sponsors and the people bringing forward
the amendment uh find some common ground
and maybe we can get another 20-0 vote
representative Muirhead thank you uh the
the the amendment refers to
um
in various places it refers to a ballot
custodian
or designee
um
and so for instance page two line 28
there's a custodian
custodian reappears at various points in
the um
in the uh such as page three line five
page three line Thirty
um and
and I it that that position is never
defined or and so I just would invite
those who are interested in this
amendment to
direct their attention to that that
position
Mr chair
I could follow up yeah please um for
instance it it I infer that that
position is invested with
responsibilities and that one of the
responsibilities will be to ensure that
those who are reviewing paper ballots
don't Mark those paper ballots but those
reviewing paper ballots only have
pencils in their possessions no pens or
other marking devices and so it's it's
actually a it's a it's a public office
invested with formal responsibilities
but those aren't ever defined in the in
I have a question
um remember
um I think when they refer to balak
custodian I think they're talking about
the clerks or the Secretary of State's
office so if that was just removed to
say Clerk or Secretary of State's office
who represent possession of the ballots
legally whoever's in Whoever has proper
possession right so not not a brand new
title called bowel custodian but the
clerk uh or the Secretary of State as
always would that would that alleviate
those concerns
it would at least clarify what you know
something about what
that person has meant who that person is
meant to be
so um if I can just point out to uh
so is that language's existing statute
though because it's not Boulder it's
Alex and I don't see a reference in
um here to add a new section against the
new subdivision
right here
oh okay yes that's all new that's all
new
so basically out of the beginning of
page two all the way to Pages yep I
understand
but it's the Hidden Music representative
work
thank you Mr chair um so in page two
lines 17 through 20 where it talks about
custody of the ballot I think the term
custodian is introduced there and it
refers to town and City Clerks and then
if the Secretary of State
um comes into possession of the ballots
then
that's where custodian is introduced so
I think
I think it's referring back to that
General paragraph and trying to
encompass
the the definite the all the positions
that could potentially have custody to
ballot in that
section
further discussion on the on the
amendment
representative Lane thank you
um I am concerned about the effective
date it says it's still 60 days after
its passage and I think as um we learned
that that means it could be applicable
to 2022
records and I would also like to have it
we've talked about addressing it so it
only comes into existence when the new
voting machines come in that can can
produce these images
um and even though it doesn't talk about
images
um I think there was kind of a long
discussion on both bills when we did 415
and 387 about that concern so I and I
haven't had time to go through this to
see but I am concerned that it's only 60
further discussion on the bill
representative Muirhead thank you and I
I think I might like to change the
amendment so that it says that towns and
cities can transfer custody of the
ballots to the Secretary of State's
office
um immediately after the election or
within a couple days after the election
so that all the responsibilities
associated with this with maintain with
giving access and making sure that
people don't Mark the ballots and
watching them constantly while they're
being reviewed are carried out
consistently across the state by one
representative Barry so I I would be
fine with that
um but I'd want a provision probably in
there about if it was only if it was
requested to for a ballot review I don't
want to send all of our balance to the
Secretary of State's office preemptively
right
um and we we kind of talked about this
in the hearing
um where you know right now when we
conduct a recount the per a recount
that's outside of the three percent
margin right that person is responsible
for the entire cost of that recount I
like to make sure I know that there's a
provision here about payment but I'd
like to make sure that it's something
like that that's iron tight if you're
going to request to do this it's a
laborious task that you are required to
pay the estimated cost up front uh and
then you're refunded any balance or
responsible for any overage the
taxpayers shouldn't be responsible for
this in any in Any Which Way
um I couldn't vote for that if it was
not like that so I'd like to see that
change on it as well
um but I I actually kind of like that
idea of just having the SOS us do it
we'd always have to talk to them but
that would make it uniform they have the
equipment already
they have a they have a cost structure
already
and it kind of alleviates some of those
concerns and then to representative
Lane's point we could change the
language about these ballot images that
we don't have yet we could put in a
trigger that you know if that is
available then you can access it
um
and I think that would solve the
because you may have some towns that
take a while to move over to the new
machines they may stay on accuvote or
whatever and if that happens you don't
want to force them to get a scanner or
something but I think that would be
probably more appropriate and that that
alleviates all the costs because then
you are just sending like a PDF or
something and I think the other thing
there's a spot in here about
um
none of this can be done until after the
recounts
um does any money I want to make sure
that that language has in there that
it's recounts and Indie pending legal
action
because a recount as we have learned a
recount does not always end on a recount
um
so I'd like I'd like to see that in
further discussion
representative wearing yes so um in page
four line 14 any legal challenge to an
election has ended would accommodate
your request I believe uh yes uh where
is that just so I can highlight it uh
it should be changed to
um until the recount period has ended
and in illegal
it shouldn't be an or it should be an
for the discussion on the amendment
representative weary thank you Mr chair
uh just one other clarification I think
uh
was talking about the printed images on
the bot toward the bottom of page four I
think the implication in Roman numeral
six is if used in the ballot counting
process maybe that language needs to be
cleared up so that it could be cited
that if uh printed images are available
you know are part of the ballot counting
process then this provision could be uh
accomplished
I think it's it's implied but not
further discussion on the amendment
one more about the cost
representative Barry uh on the cost we
need to make sure that it includes the
transportation costs of the ballots I
don't believe they currently charge for
that but if a State Trooper is going to
go out there pick the ballots up and
move it
um that person who's requesting this
needs to be financially responsible for
obviously that mileage and that state
further discussion on the amendment
representative thank you Mr chair I
really like the
um emphasis on making the requesters pay
the costs and somebody mentioned in
testimony today that there are
limitations of what can be charged to
people who make 91a requests so if we're
saying that this is a 91a eligible
request as opposed to just something
that people can request are we then
putting constraints on how much can be
charged
representative Barry so I believe my
reading of the amendment is that this is
actually not under the 91a process
um it does mention 91a up there
um but it's not I think in order to make
this work I mean it is a comp what we're
attempting to do here is it's
complicated right I I do not see a world
in which it can actually operate under
the 91a framework the 91a framework does
not allow for the payment of every
single cost and I think in order to get
this through you're going to need the
entire cost to be borne by the person
who is requesting this they're not a
candidate they're not getting a recount
they just want to see ballots in it
that's that's fine I do view these as
public documents but they need to pay
for everything and I don't think you can
even do that under a 91a I think the the
framework for 91a is just too rigid to
accomplish that so it just happens to be
I'm sorry yes please representative Lynn
um
I agree because otherwise I think we'd
have to amend 91a because at least a
quick reading of it
um earlier today was that it's just the
cost of the copies it does not include
Personnel it doesn't include this
Transportation costs it's just going to
be the cost of the copies pretty much so
if we're going to do that we either me
to reference 91a over to this or
and that makes it even more complicated
so we probably need to look at that and
see are we really amending 91a or
creating our own
kind of
representative thank you I I think so I
agree with the logic there I'm not sure
whether the um bill or the amendment is
written so that this such that this is a
separate review access right independent
of 91a and so you know in revising the
amendment some potential be need to be
paid to page one lines 22 to 26 we might
say that ballots just like it says in
the law right now ballots are exempt
from 91a there's a different access
provision that this law will
make
I I agree with that representative
Brennan thank you on page two
line
33 States any person wishing to review
ballots may make a video recording of
the viewing of the ballots
um I have a concern about that that
someone reviewing the ballots is making
a video recording and can edit that
video
to show ballots different from how they
view in person which may raise some
concerns about
um
Integrity of those ballots
um is it falsified
the video to show something different
than what the ballots actually show in
person so I that section for me does not
work
representative Barry
um so it's a it's a Fair concern you can
make the argument about a variety of
things we currently allow people during
recounts to take pictures of ballots in
fact there is a reporter who shall
remain nameless who literally shows up
and photographs every single ballot
um so I guess my counter my Counterpoint
to that which is I I don't think it's a
completely dismissable recruitment it's
a legitimate concern but my Counterpoint
to that is if there's concerns then
we've just created a process in which
somebody can come and look at it and be
like oh they manipulated the video like
are we good
all right
the question is whether to adopt
Amendment zero seven zero three h in the
no
representative prudhoma Bryan no
Representative boam no
Representative quaily no
representative Boyd no
no
representative Lane
representative Ward no
representative Hamer no
representative Hamlet no
representative LaMontagne no
representative Brennan no
representative Grill no representative
Howard
no
representative Schultz no
representative Smith
no
19 days and oh 19 days and one yay
is there a question
the question was on the vote count but I
don't think there was a second vote for
yes
all right
so we're back to the original motion of
um Ocha pass on House Bill 14 and also
the not adopting an amendment does not
work like itl on a bill that doesn't
mean the Topic's dead we just simply
didn't adopt it so in the earlier
discussion about perhaps it might belong
better someplace else
the amendment would still be in order on
that as long as it fits that bill
all right is there discussion on ought
to pass on the underlying bill
uh yes Mr representative Barry I'm
starting yes I'll be voting against
um HP 415 as it currently exists
um it's not ready for Prime Time
although I do I have changed my mind on
this subject I voted against something
similar against this last year I have
changed my mind on this uh the good news
is we have another vehicle to get this
done uh gives this committee a little
more time so 415 is not ready for prime
time but there's another bill that is
that I believe we'll be able to work on
and get ready for prime time
okay
emotion is not to pass on House Bill
415.
representative Barry no
representative Bruno Brian no
representative boom no
Representative qualey no
representative Boyd no
representative Burnham no
representative Kennedy
representative Lane no
representative Ward no
representative Hamer no
representative Hamlet no
representative warehead
representative LaMontagne no
representative Brennan no
representative Grill no
representative Howard no
representative Schultz no
was me
I'd like to move a 415 being expedient
representative Barry moves an expedient
do you want to talk about it uh very
briefly um just just to clarify well
there are people watching this one so I
know
I'm voting for itl for 4 15. the
committee will consider another vehicle
for a similar subject which I will be
supporting so I will not be voting for
14 because we have a better vehicle
for the discussion
okay
motions in expedient to legislate on
House Bill 415 when you're ready
representative Berry yes
representative Freedom O'Brien yes
representative Baum yes
representative qualey yes
representative Boyd yes
representative Burnham yes
representative wood
representative Lane yes
representative Ward yes
representative Hamer yes
representative Hamlet yes
representative mirrorhead
representative yes
representative Brennan yes
representative Grill yes representative
Howard yes
representative Schultz yes
representative Smith yes
anyone object to consent
that closes the executive session on
House Bill 415.
so it looks like I need
reports from Representatives Barry Lynn
okay
I guess what